[Music]
tim in new york city hi tim how are you
hey dave hey ken how you guys doing
today great what's up
i'm just one uh nothing much so i wanted
to know it's a two-part question there's
a human
and like left psychological element and
then there's also the financial part so
could i give you the numbers for what
our household income is and what our
debt is so far first
and then go into the question briefly
yeah sure um so our household income is
about 170
our total debt right now is about 145.
um of a hundred of which is my uh
partners student loans
um portion are you married
no okay we don't have a household income
then you have an income she has an
income
correct okay yeah okay so let's start
let's start again then let's start again
then
what is your income no problem my income
is about 85 000. okay and how much debt
do you have
i have about 22 000 worth of debt okay
and so your roommate has a hundred and
forty three thousand dollar or a hundred
and twenty three thousand dollars worth
of debt
and eighty five thousand dollar income
yes okay and yeah and how much savings
do you have
i'm sorry how much savings do you have
personally
i have about ten thousand okay and how
much does your roommate have saved
um she has about i don't know the exact
amount but somewhere between 120 and
130.
but that's part of my question okay so
my question my question is i want to
marry this girl and i see us you know
being together
indefinitely and we've been open with
each other talking about how we're going
to attack debt
we live with her parents now and we want
to pay this off so we can you know get a
house in the near future as quickly as
possible
um so we've been transparent about a lot
of things and
i wanted to ask you so the money that
she has saved is from a settlement she
got from
a medical condition that happened
through a surgery and something like
that
and she's very reluctant to part ways
with any
like significant portion of it to pay
down her student loan debt
um so i just wanted to get both of your
opinions as to
she recovered did she recover from the
medical problem
um so it's a chronic it became a chronic
nerve condition that
is long-term and can become acute you
know if something bad were to happen
or if you know you know so what does she
what does she spend on the chronic
condition per year um
right now between medication and therapy
maybe around uh
ten thousand okay a little less okay a
little less
all right so if if the amount that she
spends on her condition
doubles she could still do that easily
if she was debt free and didn't have any
money
correct okay
all right well here's the thing you
don't get to decide what other people do
with their money unless you're married
to them
and then we work on our plan together
so i'm going to fast forward in the
conversation and pretend that you're
married
but don't do this unless you're married
get the advice okay because it's bad
advice
it's bad advice when you're not married
okay she should not pay any of your debt
you should not pay any of her debt
unless there is a
marriage certificate because it's
dangerous
correct okay so if if she called me
i would understand her pain
uh uh be empathetic with her pain listen
to her
and highly encourage her to write a
check today and be debt-free
okay and then take the freedom that
she's got with an 85 000
income and begin to rebuild her
emergency fund
i would tell you to take 9 000 of your
10 and put it on your 22
uh reducing it to then uh what 11
to 13. and uh then you're gonna pay that
off very very quickly out of your 85
because you're gonna be concentrating on
it
and so probably by the time you get your
marriage uh your wedding date set and
arranged
you both could be debt free and building
your emergency funds which will put you
in a phenomenal position
to begin as a married couple to save to
buy a house later
right and that's the shortest distance
between where you are
and wealth the shortest distance between
where you are as a married couple and
financial peace in achieving your goals
thank you and if you were my kids and
you sat down at my kitchen table
which you're both younger than my kids
and so i would tell you to do exactly
that same thing and i've told i don't
know
hundreds of thousands of people just
like you to the exact same thing
in the last 30 years on this show yep
tim i would just say on the psychology
of this
to the best of your ability sit down
with your girlfriend and see
help her see what dave just explained
that she writes a check today she pays
off her debt
and between her income and health care
and the ability to be free to save
she's not going to be in a financial
deficit even with the chronic health
condition
but she's got to see that you got to
help her get there you can't tell her
you have to help show her that's the
psychology there where she gets to the
point where she goes oh
okay that's great and she's got to get
free of that fear yeah you're right if
you if
now let's change the scenario just for a
minute the reason i was asking all these
questions
because it does change the answer
actually in this one let's say she makes
eighty five thousand has 123 thousand
dollars in debt 130 000
in savings and i asked the question what
was the ongoing cost of a chronic
illness
and it's 50 000 a year now we're
probably not doing this
yeah i'm probably going to leave that
money sitting there and start to work on
the student loans out of my income
while i work through these chronic
things because that 130 000 is there to
take care of her medical needs first and
foremost that's right
at 10 000 or 20 000 it's not a big
problem mathematically
at 50 or 60 000 it starts to be a
problem